you know when you look at communal
eating and food it's such a beautiful
thing that it brings everybody together
we always had a knack for bringing like
the gangsters and hipsters together
it's been years we've been doing it for
years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is special to me because it's like a
melting pot of mixed cultures so you'll
have like the guyanese jamaican haitian
trinidadian beijing and everybody is
familiar with everybody's you know
cuisines dialect
drinks
culture way of just even being in the
caribbean it's like take it easy take it
slow whereas like in new york everything
is so fast-paced you kind of got to
remind yourself that we are human beings
and we got to take it easy and you can
actually wake up in flatbush and feel
like you're in the caribbean you know
the music and everybody getting together
and the food and the camaraderie and the
you know the laughter and the talking ah
it's just yeah
i'm nicole nicholas i'm michael nicholas
and welcome to aunts and uncles
[Music]
we're in flatbush brooklyn predominantly
west indian caribbean neighborhood my
family's from st lucia my mom is
trinidad my dad is from st vincent so
all caribbean food you know all the
things that that we make here except we
chose to go the plant-based route when
we were gonna open this space no one
understood what we were trying to build
like some people got it and some people
were like you're not thinking about your
demographic of like who's here and you
know what they already won or what they
already have i'm like that's the whole
point like there's too much of what we
already have right now people say this
is not a food desert but it kind of is a
food desert especially for you know
fresh produce and things like that and
just having family members and friends
being diagnosed with diabetes and cancer
and we decided to just choose a
healthier way of bringing the same
cuisine you know to the people of the
community
[Music]
we wanted to embrace collaboration
especially with our neighbors immaculate
is one of the first merchants on this
strip when we approached them on the
idea they were super excited and they
took the time to figure out how we were
going to do the crusty vegan it was fun
because like they're like no butter
no
eggs no milk
how do you want to do this yeah but they
mastered it it just goes to show the the
beauty of what they have over there
people eat the patties all the time i'm
glad that we were able to contribute to
that palette you know what i'm saying
and like giving people some options in a
healthier manner but it's still good
like we got the bacon sawfish it's
really good that we use horse a palm
with so that's usually made with like a
cod fish and then it gets seasoned with
things like scotch bonnet pepper thyme
onions all the same flavors all the same
textures
my aunts make a mean bake my grandmother
makes a mean bake or they call it float
in sanusha but it's pretty much the same
concept we
blend all of the ingredients together so
garlic the thyme the coconut oil the
pimento some scallion
and scotch bonnet pepper which you're
about to smell in just 2.2
like whoa
yeah feel it
this is the selfish so i'm gonna fry a
bake now
and then the minute that it starts to
float you got to flip it
my mother used to be like the big woman
you know she used to make the bakes for
everybody who wanted to have like a
family thing or if anyone came over for
christmas or you know christmas
breakfast or easters i would be like
where's the bakes mom she that she was
like the baked lady so making that here
is super special too because it kind of
keeps a piece of her in the space so you
open it it's like a bread
take your selfish
and some micros
that's your break
[Music]
i was born in the 80s so grew up in the
late 80s early 90s here in flatbush it
was totally different than what it is
right now you know this crack epidemic
and a lot of violence
so everybody wanted to figure out ways
to get out of the hood going out i
realized how much
of a gem we had here in flatbush and
even in new york city for that matter
and i realized that you know the hood is
not really like a geographical thing
it's more of a mindset
as long as you you know remove that
mindset you could see the beauty that
you have so making it in is just being
able to identify all the beauty that's
within the neighborhood and embrace it
and bring it out to the world
[Music]
ghosts what's up huh what's the vibes
bro wow it's been a while hi i'm pamela
long long long long time
so this is where brooklyn sky was wow
brooklyn sky was like t-shirts
sweatshirts hoodies yeah yeah it was fun
a lot of good times in here a lot of rap
battles and we had nipsey hustle rest in
peace guacaflocka prodigy prodigy mama
beat wrestler soul as well he just
popped up in the neighborhood like he
opened the door like yo yo where's the
chicken wing spot again
something like money later oh my god
definitely was a vegan but i know he
changed the diet because you know he was
suffering from sickle cell so i know
like there was a point of time where he
was more conscious of what he was taking
i mean in the hip hop community look at
fat joe he said he lost like five or so
of his homies like heart attacks back to
back to back to back
and his eye opener it's like yo damn
this is really the food that we're
really doing just to ourselves even more
plant forward it's just like you consume
life and rather than consuming so much
depth you know what i'm saying a plate
of curry goat has like
you know the limbs of like seven billy
goats you know what i mean like ram
goats just like
ran this ran he might have been
depressed one day this guy is happy and
this one is shocked and this is like and
all of that stuff he was just like
taking all that energy yeah it's all
energy we all energy you know that
already
[Music]
we're about to head over to our buddy
lonnie's career during the pandemic line
he used to have like a little stoop
session
and he would just invite a few friends
and we'll talk about everything and talk
about
government we talk about politics we
talk about sports you talk about
nightlife talk about food a super dope
creative in the community and super
influencer so we bout to go to his stoop
and he's right in our hood so we're
going to take that walk
hey what's going on do y'all want a
drink anybody need water
i got bottled water inside no drinks or
anything
lonnie's kind of like we we share a lot
of ideas with him and vice versa and
i'll give him a real answer like yo i
think this rocks or nah i think that's a
terrible idea you shouldn't do that [ __ ]
so
when they first told me the idea
i was like holy [ __ ] that's fine you
could throw a rock hit a jamaican
restaurant and trade wrestling rod
but the entire concept of what austin
uncles is with vegan food and you know
sustainability practices and just being
like cool bars about to chill at but
also having like retail stuff
that was just not a thing it's proof
that the neighborhood's like flatbush
have people in them that are
transformative that can come in and
build the concept that's sustainable
within the neighborhood and then people
from the outside right showing you come
in and want to like join or whatever but
the wave was built from inside we didn't
have to like you know go outside like
this is built right here in the hood
like big boy said it from outcast is
that you want to make it in the world
you got to start from your corner you
choosing to open the spot on the block
like you could have gone so many other
places people didn't want to come here
like that people like wait where you
live at flatbush now we good there was a
couple of people that were like you
should just open back on the block i'm
like
i don't know like but [ __ ] if burger
king can sell a vegan burger why can't
you that's it you know so we're working
on it we're building it you know i mean
because nothing like this has existed in
our space for us you know i mean just
having people kind of understand the
concept is um has been taking a little
time a couple people have come to the
cafe like
you guys should raise the prices i'm
like why yeah
like we're not in an affluent
neighborhood you know what i'm saying so
it's like it should be accessible it's
interesting that you've like taken the
onus to like you know lower your prices
when people in our community spend so
much money on other [ __ ] elsewhere like
they spend a ton of money on like you
know clothing or like sneakers or shoes
like fashion goods but it's just the
mentality of what you put into your body
you won't spend the highest amount to
make sure that you're healthy
but you'll spend it on a pair of
sneakers and i say this as a guy with a
very large sink collection but i like
food is one thing i paid for when i
first opened up i came like yo whatever
i want everything on the menu just give
it to me yeah i mentioned that you made
the
heirloom pasta
i came in one night just to hang out and
you were like yo um
we got a pasta you want to try it i'm
like all right
you're like yo whoa this is fine
no i got to tell everybody about this
but it's funny because there'll be times
like back in the day we're moving around
yo this is mike from brook and scott oh
okay guys right here hi mike oh yo this
is mike from dm yeah oh hi mike that's
michael oh i know
right yeah that's amazing that's right
here we go
high five
[Music]
you know it's very different how people
look at food
now you know like to say you're a chef
so not necessarily traditionally trained
but like just the creativity of cooking
at home you know to say like i'm going
to feed people you know that takes a lot
of guts to even attempt that you know
because cooking for yourself is one
thing cooking for your partner is
another thing your family and your
friends but then cooking for a whole
community that's a big big task so it's
really cool to be able to
have that confidence and have those
ambitions and have those dreams and
sharing it with the community and once
you put it into the universe it's just
it has to come to life at that point in
time you know put into the universe
it'll come through yeah and with the
neighborhood changing so much the way
that it is i'm happy that we're here and
we hope to be here for a long time so
that we can keep little caribbean alive
you know that's super important because
it's a special place
we both have these moments together and
separately when we kind of sit here and
it's completion and we're just like oh
wow you know we never thought not to say
never thought but just as fast as things
are happening like we're like monk nine
and
we're on complex like it's a big deal
that's fire we'll tell some vegetables
and plants will make it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you